hey I'm Kira damn Butch Hartman I'm
creative some shows at Nickelodeon that
are animated what are we doing today
today we are drawing Nicktoons from this
will be fun cuz I don't know what era
Nicktoons yeah thousands era 90s era if
you were in a 900 era I have a chance
but first be sure to stick around till
the end of the video to find out how you
can enter for a chance to win this walk
them into a tablet experience
experiments portray creativity Munir in
Novant Jackie will not be their new
spokesperson Bonjour are you ready
Jackie I'm ready are you are you good
with the Nicktoons I did watch my
nicktoons you know okay I watched a lot
more of it the older I got your
character today is Doug Doug funnie now
Doug I've seen I've actually seen done
wait wait wait Ren was the Chihuahua
Stimpy was the cat right yeah yeah yeah
wait friend no Ren's the cat Stimpy's
the Chihuahua I think the whole oh boy
which one are we drawing again day I'm
drawing right all right Stan wearing
Stimpy what oh wait pressures on because
as you know Butch Hartman is here to
ridicule and mock us for our drawing so
we better be good so we better be good
yeah there we go
yeah the cat okay so he's just like a
big round and he's red right yeah isn't
he wearing gloves wrong I am yes I think
he is here's the thing about Ren and
Stimpy too so they actually go off model
a lot yes so there's not really like one
very like canonical like form that they
take so this is not a style that I
usually draw and it's very angular it's
very much in the UPA style with TPA UVA
stands for Universal productions of
America they were a popular production
company
in the 50s and 60s responsible for a lot
of kind of angular styles that you see
and like Dexter's Laboratory and stuff
like that I see well you think your
biggest inspiration was it changed a lot
I think like as a kid or really loved
you know like pokemon digimon that sort
of cute anime style mm-hmm and then got
more into cartoons that I got more into
like the UPA hanna-barbera big stuff
oh my god I feel like a child again
drawing this yeah like just struggling
to draw like your favorite characters
don't forget them very related items
okay yeah I remember I mean obviously
she has wings mm-hmm there's another
thing you can't forget it what is it
they always have it coming their wands
there's another thing Kevin oh my god
why figure it out again 9 8 7 5 4 3
I don't know their crowns Oh crowns
freak them out you did freak me I would
have forgotten the crown thank you for
telling you're welcome what is the
origin story behind Fairly OddParents
thank you for asking I was at Cartoon
Network at the time we're on the Johnny
Bravo show and that show was about to
end and I was gonna lose my job and you
know you have to pay the bills and
that's like well I need a job and I was
tired of working for other people and so
finally I said I'm gonna make my own
show so I literally sat down and I said
what if I was gonna make a show of
anything what would I make I thought
well I'll make a show about a little boy
we always write or draw what we know
right I drew this little kid I decided
to call him Timmy because I've got a
brother named Timmy oh I also have a
brother named Mike I was gonna met my
brother Michael we had a fight that day
hey you lost your chance man no Mike's a
great guy but so anyway I came with the
show with Timmy I'm like what can I do
with him no that's that way be cool to
give him like a way to get around
quickly I felt I could teleport him like
you know science stuff but I couldn't do
science stuff because Dexter's Lab was
already out and so I decided well I
could use I could make magic so I
thought well I can give the kid magic
powers or give them a magic friend so I
gave him
Wanda I drew Wanda first I thought okay
he's got a magic fairy godmother like
Cinderella I call that boys version
Cinderella that'll be fun I've never
seen a fairy godfather before so I drew
Cosmo all of this took about 15 minutes
really
that's kind of cool yeah just kind of
went from there oh this is a sad a sad
day for Jason and Bryn straw furrier
yeah yeah I don't think I really
captured his personality much like this
is like some mischievous gremlin you
know what I don't know Wanda's colors
you don't know Cosmo and Wanda's colors
they're very I mean I mean I know that
Wanda is a redhead hmm right red right
Oh going downhill oh no no no no come on
you have to tell me am i right is she a
redhead
what inferior edit you know what I'm
making her a redhead I'm committing to
it all right Kyra how you doing over
there think pretty good trying to
remember his outfit you know as much as
I'm struggling I think this looks like
him oh okay I think you could look at
this and go oh yeah that's Stimpy I
think exactly what that inflection is
what someone would say if these new
monitors are cuz it gives me so much
space these monitors make me feel like a
king it makes me feel like I'm drawing
for the Queen oh no this doesn't look
right
oh I thought I was doing well and now
just at the end up stumbling the color I
screwing up the color Jackie helped me
well right what are you doing wrong is
she a redhead no Kevin what a shot of
redhead Cosmo is green what looks good
with green red orange Jackie helped me
go down the color line come on pink yeah
she has pink hair yes big minds has done
as I'll ever want it to be okay I'm done
I think I can't I can't possibly put any
more Doug in here and I am putting my
pen down all right Jackie how'd you do I
don't think it looks on model mmm
as much as I wanted it to I thought I
could do better than this honestly but
still I think it's not too far off did
okay I think maybe this is a close
representation of Doug it's like Doug's
cousin if I had to grade my performance
today I would say solid c-minus not
employable at Nicola
at this time I've already grade my
performance I'd give it a D oh man
you're more harsh greater yeah I don't
know why I thought I pass I think I'm a
detail I think I stumbled with the color
but I think I got the general
construction I think I got the face okay
we'll see okay I'm ready
switch e ties which II oh yeah he's
gonna go watch fairly often that's
really about like his pose Thank You
Alan here is brown pants doesn't he oh
wait okay you like got him this is
basically him right this is so far off I
love whoever this is I love yours oh
thanks it's exactly what you said it's
not on model mm-hmm but it is very cute
I like yours I like that your wand isn't
even complete like you thought it was
like a magician's right it's always like
sparkly at the end it's got a star
though no boy oh no boy it looks like
Wanda it's just the little things that
are wrong this dippy is a great addition
to the draw off-brand character universe
very good very nice drawing
thank you Sam your art so our story
it's like Ed Edd n Eddy almost like you
ever that like she loved that show that
shaky line that shaky let get purposeful
lines were really cool oh man Wow yeah
yours is so far off I love it you know
what I got the hairs on the top of his
head you did okay yeah yeah you got the
rest of it
dang he has no toes though he doesn't
man I got a way out you got the shoe
color correct you're almost dead on
that's really good I know I got the
pants color wrong my face shape is
different my nose shape is the raw your
nose is down like Doug's nose I think
you know what that's for the one I got
the most wrong well very cool nice
working with you
YouTube is very charming and I wish you
nothing but the best and all that you do
thank you see well thank you we're in
the street out here in the BuzzFeed
world is that Jackie and Kevin are
drawing my characters now so if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna get over there and
see what's going on that okay
hey how do I get out of here okay kids
giveaway time if you want to enter for a
chance to win this welcome in to us
tablet all you have to do is go to the
BuzzFeed comics Instagram that's at
comics on Instagram find this post and
follow the instructions in the caption
best of luck to you sheriff justice huh
I'll do it well you're drawing pictures
this is Kevin's picture this is Kevin
this is but this is Jack these are very
cute here let me show you what the real
Wanda looks like you guys be the judge
there's Wanda alright what do you think
well we got that we get the hair swirl
right she put highlights in the eyes
though she gave us a little Walt Disney
going to marry Jackie now kevin has got
a real this was the sound of seeing this
is very Sanjay and Craig okay have you
seen Sanjay great it's cool to see
another style so do you guys there did
you ever draw Fairly OddParents before
this is literally my first time drawing
drawing anything no drawing oh so butch
while you're here can you tell us a
little bit about the design style for
The Fairly OddParents so you're saying
before that's very kind of you PA
inspired when I first did this at
Nickelodeon I thought well I'll just do
something I've never done before so I'll
be honest with you I sort of based it a
little bit on John Kriss pallucci style
a little bit but as the show went on I
sort of created a language like all the
characters have the same shape head I
love that design style of like yeah UPA
hanna-barbera back in the 60s if you
look at Wanda's hair it's like warm
flesh nose okay exactly and so yeah
everything comes from somewhere well
thank you for critiquing our drawings
yes we greatly appreciate it or welcome
I will magically disappear out of here
here I go no no it's fine you didn't
almost hit anything
[Music]